on passe à notre terriens du samedi soir
[Musique]
gary garcia bonsoir bon ça
disait tu attends gary du syndrome de
gilles de la toile c'est à dire que vous
êtes submergé par des vagues de tics
verbaux qui vous pousse à insulter ceux
que vous croisez la famille les amis les
collègues de travail mais aussi des
inconnus des serveurs des caissières pas
c'est un peu comme laurent baffie quoi
c'est un peu sauf que moi je suis payé
pour ça voilà je les payais moi j'ai un
médecin un mot du médecin voilà
on regarde
[Musique]
ça va tu as bien dormi du web nous et
pas trop chaud tu t'en fiches de plus je
prends vous deviez prendre du café ouais
tête à
deux mains
alors
examinons pas de ressasser fils de [__]
dans le cul
plus stressés de ce qu'il ya à faire
avant
[Musique]
tu baises
omar salut
je te dis merde
et ce soir encore est heureusement vous
avez décidé d'en rire gary aujourd'hui
vous êtes un salarié heureux et qui peut
insulter son patron en toute impunité
[__]
s'emmerde en mai m6 catholique et
concret tueur et ses laquais je n'ai pas
tous les lycéens les hommes étaient sur
toi moi je le reconnais alors garé il
est né le 17 juillet
1990 à gleizé dans le rhône un père
chauffeur à la dde la direction
départementale de l'équipement mère
femme au foyer
une grande soeur de grand frère
vous êtes très proche de votre grand
père je ne m'étends pas habité juste à
côté de la maison familiale avec une
idée de maisons communiqué qantas est un
des scénarii gc qui avant de dire
bonjour une plongée voir mes grands
parents je passe un petit moment avec
lui et puis je suis parti après avoir
mes parents
lorsque votre grand père décède en 1998
vous avez huit ans c'est un choc
terrible pour vous
à partir de là vous développez des tics
moteurs cet hymne à réjean de son épaule
mais mon dieu comme sarko
et bientôt en plus des tics moteurs
c'est le langage qui se met à dérailler
comment ça se passe
début c'était puisse des singles vocaux
et non verbaux donc des raclements de
gorge des to et après ça a été
plus sur des sur des mots mais qui avait
aucun sens ça pouvait être tarte au
chocolat
fraises 1 n'importe quoi à l'école
évidemment les élèves se moque de vous
et les médecins ne comprennent pas
s'envisager
ils comprennent pas enfin ils n'ont pas
dit si tu es tout de suite avec ce
syndrome saleh à voir depuis plus d'un
an des tics moteurs et verbaux et je
n'avais que des tics moteurs à l'époque
où j'allais voir les médecins alors là
vous vous réfugier dans le travail
scolaire
une bonne idée parce que ça vous a rendu
bon à l'école ouais je pense que j'ai
choisi à ce moment là le bon côté du
syndrome mois réfugiés du bon côté de la
barrière on va dire plutôt que les gens
qui se renferme sur eux mêmes ouais et
c'est ça que je veux montrer c'est qu'on
peut ça nous de choisir quand même on
peut y arriver
alors vous êtes dans le 4e canton un
neurologue vous prescrit du risperdal à
forte dose le prévenu risque pénal c'est
que les effets secondaires sont sont
terribles et vous passez vos journées à
dormir en cours en fait vous ratez votre
seconde à cause du risperdal
et vous arrêtez de risperdal pendant un
temps j'avais plutôt de de traitement
médical et du coup j'ai fait j'ai
beaucoup plus de tic mais ça m'a pas
empêché de le faire mais par un internat
où vous êtes les moqueries se sont
transformés en harcèlement et surtout
harcèlement psychologique
sur vos tic mais aussi sur votre taille
et votre poids alors j'étais au bord de
la dépression
vous avez même du mal à en parler de
tout ça quoi beaucoup de mal à ce que je
voudrais pas face par mes parents avec
ça il faut dire que vous commencez à ce
moment-là à développer vos premiers tics
de langage
quand vous lisez par exemple un texte
vous répéter trois ou quatre fois les
les deux derniers mots de la phrase quoi
alors évidemment ces tic sont un
obstacle pour réaliser votre rêve oublié
travaillé dans la marine
la [__]
non pas celle là je vais m'engager la
marine c'est pour ça que je m'étais mis
un bac pro dans un bac pro qui est en
partenariat avec la marine nationale
alors autre difficulté les mots sortent
de votre bouche sans stimuli extérieurs
au défunt maintenant je gère mieux les
contrôler et j'avais avoir une
discussion à peu près normal j'en ai
toujours deux ou trois qui sortent et d
alors en fin de deuxième année de bac
pro 1 euro psychol impose enfin le bon
diagnostic
vous êtes atteints du syndrome gilles de
la tourette depuis dix ans c'est ça à la
rentrée de troisième année du dut bac
pro le harcèlement dont vous êtes
victimes à l'école s'intensifie on vous
change de classe et là vous tombez sur
un prof d'électronique qui prend le
temps d'expliquer aux autres élèves le
mal dont vous souffrez ce à partir de ce
moment là que j'ai vraiment commencé à
l'accepter et dit j'ai pu l'expliquer
aux autres et ça ça aide énormément le
diable l'aja se passe bien vous intégrer
au goût dresser un c'est naturellement
ce et à partir de l'âge qui est très
important c'est qu'on ne rit plus contre
vous mais avec vous c'est ça j'ai appris
en rire je les laissais vraiment
acceptée par la dérision grâce à mes
camarades de terminale skis simon qui
m'ont beaucoup aidé en intégrant dans
leur groupe
et j'ai appris en rire et j'en ris
encore au jour d'aujourd'hui parce que
je voyais mes collègues de travail à
temps plein la gueule et puis si si je
fais tout ce que je dis elles en
prennent plein de culot si quoi
en 2009 vous décrocher enfin votre bac
pro vous vous inscrivez en bts dont le
même établissement et curieusement c'est
là que commencent à apparaître les tics
de langage à caractère sexuel les jurons
les insultes des vagues d'insanités
impossible à réprimer jeu technique je
te beige t'encule [__] cattin tête de
biton face à yb a rien
à voir lexique à ce qui est marrant
c'est que dès que vous entendez un
nouveau jour on vous l'intégrer vous
avez des amis portugais vous intégrez
les jurons portugais vous intégrer des
jurons en allemand
en arabe aussi j'ai vraiment une éponge
en fait si j'entends les insultes dans
une phase où je suis en stress ou
anxieux je vais intégrer plus facilement
antique et c'est plus ou moins
contraignants sur un répondant temps on
regarde
[Musique]
donc
merci bien
pourquoi il est caissière quoi n'importe
quand je choisis pas au moment où je
prends une crise un problème mais pour
draguer sera peut être réduit donc quand
même basket si le premier rendez vous
vous dites [__] à la fille ça dépend
ça marche salut marché
[Applaudissements]
2011 vous décrochez votre bts et là il
faut trouver du boulot pas évident non
quand on insulte ses collègues et son
patron ben j accueille les patrons aux
entretiens d'embauché
bonjour [__] ça jette un froid car ça
peut rapprocher aussi tout dépendra pas
content à avoir reculé c'est le plus
gentil gère way et le pire c'est quoi un
jeu assez de vraiment violent va là bas
on va attendre
[Applaudissements]
mais
vous finissez par vous faire une place
au sein d'une équipe dans une société
qui fabrique du matériel médical et
m'ont très bien acceptée avec ma maladie
il en rigole avec moi justement ouais et
si jamais d'autres que dans la journée
je suis je me sens fatigué que j'ai
besoin de dévaluer meti qui me laisse
cinq dix minutes pour sortir tranquille
dehors tout seul mais évacuer retourner
bosser après moi que c'est très
appréciable alors quand vous passez
votre oral aussi les examinateurs sont
extrêmement bienveillant et vous en
faites
oui parce que vu ce que je leur ai dit
comme insulte et j'ai réussi à l'avoir
oui je suis ont été très bienveillant au
regard
suivant du constat suivant la taille ou
l'aspect des cartons 6 m on a un
planning juste ici saleh sur les banques
une [__] sur les des différentes
salles de production on a deux relèvent
par jour
bonjour
[Musique]
merci gary pour ta présentation taillieu
rien tant plaisir on a apprécié de
donc nous présente donc attendre
activité professionnelle ce qu'on a
décidé d'un commun accord avec les
membres du jury ici présents et à
supérieur patricia donc pour ce qui est
à soutenance d'aujourd'hui en a validé
l'ensemble des capacités
professionnelles ont été écrits
[Applaudissements]
enfin vous êtes technicien
logistique
que j'ai décidé donc maintenant j'ai un
boulot de reprendre et votre votre vie
en main ouais fête du sport vous ai
perdu 28 kg en quatre mois comme
stendhal je crois qu'on peut vous
féliciter demandé
épouse occupé d'une course qui s'appelle
les foules et anthony donc il ya lieu
demain d'ailleurs ça fait voilà vous
participez à l'organisation de cette
cette course il va un blog qui est
destiné à ceux qui sont atteints du même
syndrome que vous alors faute
donc sur ce blog c'est ce soit les
personnes qui l'ont soit surtout des
parents d'enfants qui ont le syndrome
qui sont un peu perdus des réponses des
conseils comment on peut vivre avec et
du fonds s'appuient tolère marché on a
on a des bons retours de la part des
parents
j'ai un autre projet en tête ce serait
de faire des des conférences dans des
écoles pour expliquer vraiment syndrome
est alors voulais remercier laurent
baffie pour sa pièce toc toc d'abord on
regarde à quoi ça ressemble
vous auriez vous
échappé
quoi dans la photo pour voir ce que tu
viens de dire non car je tenais ma mère
de plus donc je vous verrai bien vouloir
accepter mes excuses je ne fais pas
exprès voyons d'abord tu traites vers de
[__] à petit excuses des tapis futé
chaîne pas un gros perdants ta gueule ou
encore une fois je vous prie d'accepter
toutes mes excuses je suis victime de ce
que les spécialistes appellent le
syndrome gilles de la tourette
mais toi c'est
[Musique]
moi le cac de lanvin sur scène en ce
moment
[Musique]
tu es le seul à avoir écrit sur les
toques nous alors quand j'ai écrit sur
les toques je me suis beaucoup documenté
à telle enseigne que j'ai des souvenirs
où je je je chiale est derrière
l'ordinateur parce que j'ai quantifier
toute la souffrance qu'il peut y avoir
enfin j'ai vu vraiment aller pas se
moquer j'ai mis un point d'honneur à ne
pas me moquer d'eux de ça parce que
c'était facile de le faire il ya une
bonne note du monde mais ça reste dans
le respect quand même de la maladie et
c'est vrai que j'ai trouvé beaucoup du
moins là dedans et ça m'a aidé à 1,6
mais les gens qui ont ce talent problème
c'est qu'ils peuvent pas avoir de
représentation sociale et vous vous
démontrer le contraire parce que vous
êtes compris vous êtes accepté et vous
pouvez avoir une vie dans une entreprise
et tout le monde sait ce que vous avez
c'est pas grave merci de votre
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu